[Music]
let's do this river babes welcome to the
sweet letter secrets preview show for
episode 305 chapter 40 the Great Escape
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and today
I'm channeling my inner juggy because
well he takes center stage at the crazy
concert in this week's episode and I'm
just trying to make sense of it all now
in this episode I'll be bringing you my
three clues about the next all new
episode of Riverdale as well as gifting
you with an exclusive interview with
Lilly Reinhardt and matron emic that's
sure to make your serpent loving selves
smile but as for your hisses kisses and
theories you guys left me over 800
comments on the last Sweetwater
after-show for chapter 39 The Midnight
Club and here are a few that caught my
eye first up a lot of you were oh so
peeved about something in the last
episode but I think Lisa Pitt said it
best
she wrote hisses - still not hearing the
actor's voice who played Jason slash
young Clifford it's been two and a bit
seasons and we haven't heard him speak
damn Lisa you're so right by the way
that actor's name is Trevor Stein's
and to be honest I wonder at this point
if it's just a running joke in the
Riverdale's writer room to not give him
any lines keeping it going with the
blossom family frustrations Oreo girl
posted I'm still confused on where
Claudius was if he even exists yes where
was Claudius in the flashback don't you
think Penelope would have mentioned in
her incestuous explanations that her
adoptive brother slash future husband
also has an identical twin or are we
still in agreement that Claudius is just
Clifford blossom in disguise after he
faked his own death and has anyone
checked on Nana Rose she's not next up
elf forest home commented hisses to
there being no Mary Andrews she wasn't
even mentioned didn't she go to River
Bell hi I know right the fact that Mary
Andrews who is played by Breakfast Club
princess herself Molly Ringwald was not
in the flashback episode is
mind-boggling to me where were you Molly
I'm not going
discuss my private life with total
strangers moving on hailey McGee came in
hot with one of the biggest questions of
the week saying what was featherhead
doing in the girls bathroom drinking
blue liquid Thank You hailey I think
we'd all like to know the answer to that
one the whole feather her death was just
Nick there's nothing better to do and
Ilana I go at it
kisses to LeAnn for looking exactly like
young Alice where is the CW with your
contract
oh thanks Alana now I'm flattered you
all enjoyed my young Alice look but if I
were on the CW then I couldn't bring you
river babes to new episodes of
Sweetwater each week so I'm gonna take
this time right now to tell you to
subscribe so you never miss an episode
and lastly Katherine McCleary commented
kisses - Lilly's acting I loved her ed
young sassy Alice especially her comment
about where the Hall Pass was I what's
up your ass Penelope
I completely agree Katherine and I loved
Lily Reinhart in this episode so much
and they know that you all are going to
love watching Betty let her hair down
literally in episode 305 as she embarks
on a very important serpent mission but
here's one thing that I'm still
impatiently waiting for when is Betty
gonna get her Southside tattoo I don't
know
we already saw from that sultry phallus
scene that Alice's tat is slithering up
her thigh so when I caught up with Lily
in Mei Chen I asked them to give me some
inky answers take a look
did you have any say as to where Alice's
serpent tattoo would be placed yes I
chose the spot I put it on and then I
sent it to Roberto to approve and he
liked it Lily i talked to roberto about
if / when betty will be getting her
serpent Queen tattoo yeah he said it's
safe to assume that will happen at some
point this season that's news to me you
know that at one point en idea that
Alice and Betty we're gonna go get a
serpent a two together right but Yuri
but now I already see very really
already yeah have you thought about
where you would want Betty's to be no
we're obvious because I don't want to
have to get a fake tattoo on
work I was I already have to get my
tattoos covered constantly so I'm like I
don't need a longer hair and makeup time
somewhere like where her mom's is maybe
just like her mama like mother and I'm
trying to think of like I'll see
something that's hidden by a bathing
suit something like that just the ass
[ __ ] stamp it on the damn what do you
guys think should Betty get a serpent
stamp slither on down to the comments
and weigh in with your thoughts and now
let's take a look at what's coming up
next in the promo for chapter 40 look
great escape
the more I play Morrissey patterns whose
game messes with your head are you
comfortable
it's now or never Archie his life is in
danger this is not a game
you are the light outrunning the
darkness Archie okay that was a lot
biggest takeaway Archie and Joaquin kiss
what now are you guys tantalized or
confused honestly I feel like this
entire season has just been a combo of
those two emotions
I'm tanto fused so let's see if I can
tan to fuse you with my three clues
about episode 305 number one a blonde
beauty finally shares a smooch with the
former boy next door number two three
characters band together but they'll
betray another in the process and number
three one serpentine aims to give you a
heart attack so brace yourselves for an
epic King clap back and now we're done
thank you so much for watching today's
preview show for chapter 40 the greatest
faith and then check back with me after
you see episode 305 for our Sweetwater
secrets after-show and some new bromance
scoop from KJ Appa
but for now hit the comments and see if
you can crack my three tanta fusing
clues what do you think is gonna happen
in this week's episode where do you
think Betty should get her serpent
tattoo and is anyone else worried about
Jughead let all your thoughts and I'll
see you soon river babes tada
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]